[Music]
what up guys welcome back to another
episode of hot seat oh my god today we
got a special guest we got little taika
hey welcome back to hot seat hey what's
up tycoon
[Applause]
we got a little who's a little poop
you're you're a little poo
all right tycho hey as you know on hot
seat we like to start a little cold so
we're gonna we're gonna open show a
little cold
so the iceman should start it off cold
so i'll just ask you this how much do
you love your mom and dad fireman
fireman good environment how much do you
love papa
a lot what about mama
a little bit with a poop
that sounds better
a little bit with poop
do you love your mommy or daddy more i
don't like daddy more than mom with
would you say that she's hella poop or a
hackapoo poo he got donut poop
poop
oh yeah a little bit of dutch bros
like donut holes yeah and i'm gonna put
my buns
a little bit yeah
which one is your favorite spider-man
toby
tom or andrew
toby mcguire and um and andrew
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
do you like spiderman or thor he just
said he likes venom he was licking all
of the [ __ ]
hey taiga do you like jiu jitsu no i
like comics
but you like jiu jitsu too don't you
like jiu jitsu
that is guarded you have to have the
mind of a child to understand what he's
doing and i completely got it taco
what's your favorite jackie chan movie
um
mr nice type baby mr nice guy let's go
it was really cool taika how do you feel
about feminism today
okay cool taika is cancelled so
taka what's your favorite pedro amadovar
movie
spiderman
what do you think about the war between
russia and ukraine um
hey look right here look what's your
message for vladimir putin tonight yeah
yeah
vladimir putin
[Laughter]
but
[Music]
he's trying to silence you he's trying
to silence
is the earth flat or round round but not
how do you feel about the mask mandates
like but she's like a video game
punching like a video game like a video
game i'm sensing a theme i'm not sure
what it is i'm not too sure pick it up
all right
four hits in a row taka you've been
learning um the ancient art of music
but you've been learning the intro but
i'm sorry i'm sorry ancient art
i didn't know i was looking at my carbs
all right bad journalism
hey did uh do you believe that the
coronavirus came from eating bats oh
gross
it is gross
yeah
yeah i get that what's your favorite
song
sunflower butt can you sing it so
everyone could hear maybe never
you got a crush on anybody from school
yet
oh yeah
that's a guess
would you say that's that's how many
more years you wanted trump to be
president
no you're gonna be poop oh damn are you
ready
what's your favorite color
black you like black
who farts more daddy or mommy daddy
whose butt smells better mommies are
papas
mommy cause cause you're burnt on me
we hear the truth yo
bart's over farting on his child
remember the last time you sneeze on me
when did i sneeze on you
i was getting too cute it was getting
too cool yeah
are you afraid about you know robots
dominating the human race or like is
that i'm not scared of any of those
facts
not even artificial intelligence get out
the poop you're scared of poop we are
all scared
the poop monster killed my brother he
took my brother from me so when you say
that
it hurts my feelings
oh
he said he's gonna kill the poop yeah
yes
you're back
hey how would you kill the poop monster
what's a lifesaver with a lightsaber
that's right up steve's street that's
really cool
taco would you say that you use a light
side uh lightsaber or dark side
lightsaber
this was the poop monster
what would you do
that's what if that was the poop monster
gross don't put it in your mouth dude it
smite me it [ __ ] you tuck it away
what if that was the poop monster what
would you do
yeah stretch them out
i was trying to put them in the trash
can
put them in the trash can
throw
would you ever take scissors and cut uh
eyes off of snails no
right it's so bad
i'm not that weird after all
tycho what crypto should i invest in
butt snail but i should have seen it
coming was right there
it's gonna pump now for sure big time
okay before this comes out
i'm gonna get butt snail i i would get
people's names beeping snails tycho
what's spiderman's webs made out of
and then you can't say butt yeah it's
not made out of butt i know we already
know it's not i rather
spiderweb
holy [ __ ] this guy knows his stuff he
knows another word
who's stronger carnage or venom
after um bad one that's the hardest
question he's ever been asked last one
with the black one it's the bad one
oh venom is a bad one yeah the it was
just two of them one's a good one once
about when it comes to the battle and
he's just right he's trying to beat him
so he relates more to carnage that's
frightening
his parents are here
who's stronger than miles morales
or carnage
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
do you like the ninja turtles
which one's your favorite ninja turtle
don't say poop he's not a ninja turtle
yeah
[Laughter]
but why do you like rafael he's the mean
one
and he always do like
oh with the symbols yeah he's getting
his guys
and then he
[Laughter]
he can dodge questions better than a
politician
scary face really good can you go to the
bathroom by yourself yet
imagine you asked joe biden that
question he's like
wow amazing
all right time to heat it up okay this
is the 10 minute 54 second uh part of
the show where we like to try to eat so
tyka out of your mom or your dad
wha who who would you say needs therapy
the most today's video is brought to you
by tushy when i first discovered the
bidet i was kind of intimidated but when
i was going back to my motherland of
japan right i started noticing that
these things are everywhere and public
park bathrooms i was shocked right i had
to give it a shot you know that shot
cleaned my butt hole like i just
showered and i felt like this is awesome
because i always thought about if we
ever touch kaka and get it smeared all
over our arm
are we going to get a napkin and just
smear it off dust it off that's the
american way yeah you want to wash it
clean it
and then you want to take it out right
yeah and i'm like that's the same thing
for your butthole yeah that's probably
way cleaner yeah and i'm super thankful
because toushi hooked me up with my very
own bidet set and i love it it's super
easy to install it took less than eight
minutes so fast and you don't need any
electricity or anything like that it
uses the whole system that it already
has in the toilet it even cuts down on
toilet paper usage by 80
because you just spray your little
butthole and then you just pat and dry
and that's it and it's going to be the
cleanest you ever feel and it's so true
because i save so much money i barely
buy toilet paper now yeah and especially
during the pandemic if people are gonna
run into the market and buy all the
toilet paper you don't have any toilet
paper to use don't worry you got tushy
yeah i go you take all the toilet paper
i'm gonna wash my ass with water and
then i'm gonna use my sock to pat and
dry
we want all of our listeners to have
clean bums visit hellotuition.com off
the record to get ten percent off plus
free shipping damn
tag us and at hello to us on social
media so we can celebrate your clean
butt with you that's hello to she dot
com slash off the record for ten percent
off so taika out of your mom or your dad
who who would you say needs therapy the
most mom or your daddy mom or daddy
i'll put them in the fridge and it's
gonna go with the vegetables underneath
cryotherapy
okay and then i'll put them and then
that made sense to me yeah i agree yeah
i don't need a translator for that
baby
that's all about the thing from all of
your years of being on this earth how
old are you four but so for four years
what do you what do you regret
the most what is your biggest life
regret
stupider
oh
jupiter
[Music]
what's your favorite planet
jupiter
jupiter jupiter
you don't like mars you don't like
uranus this is like right there for you
it's right there
no but you missed it you missed it
you missed your anus you missed it i got
your eyeball
nice hey what's your favorite food
[Music]
oh
very modern answer he likes rump roasts
hair like i was on his back on his
shoulders
he's gonna eat your hair oh no no you
don't eat hair tycoon you're a hair
eater tycho do you like to eat hair yep
i could but i can't but other than
popping back in the restaurant that's
him on his shoulder i say
yeah look a little like a
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's pretend your uncle joe just
recently came into a lot of money what
should he do with it what's a reasonable
thing to do
what do you like better china or mexico
chinese
are you mexican nope i'm chinese
[Laughter]
you got that steve confidence he just
put a whole country in the garbage he
just said everyone can relax
you're mexican did you know that
you know you're mexican mom
yes you're mexican
but you speak spanish
that wasn't your butt cheek
tyco
this whole time you've been talking
about butt cheeks we didn't know you're
talking about feet
[Music]
dude bart what are you teaching this guy
you told him that that's a butt cheek i
don't know this guy's a mine of his own
man i heard that brother hey guys
death penalty yes or no
hey both you said butt
oh classic butter butter
is it over for us is this the last
episode of jk probably nope you're a
snack man oh we're
that's what he said we're stuck here i
thought he said nope you're a snackman
that's my thought too
iceman snackman i do i
like snacks
tacos so you could speak spanish
can you say something in spanish um
salad salad salad filled spanish four
times it's ensalada but how do you say
apple in spanish
no i think
my name is
do you like to dance no i know i guess
my book taika what is one word of advice
that you would give to your younger self
boy
wow nice
gotta eat your vegetables you guys gotta
eat your vegetables
to be healthier why he doesn't eat his
vegetables at home no he does saka do
you wish you were a big brother i i had
a baby brother right to care for me
who's your baby brother
do you remember you you you take care of
your
your baby
you talking about comment
yeah ben carl you got baby
oh cause they kept saying that this
baby's his little brother oh psycho who
what's your which one's your favorite
asian gang
[Laughter]
even he likes that question watching
asian boys what about the cool boys boys
do you want a baby bro do you want a
little brother a little sister
a little butt
well can you do it guys
he's so funny dude i will end up with
one last question what's the last
question we're going to finish tyco
remember you told me
that you want to get married no i don't
yeah but you didn't but you don't want
to get married to a girl right nope i
know but you can't
who are you gonna marry who are you
gonna marry and don't say a butt because
we already know you're probably married
nope nope
who are you gonna marry who no you're
not gonna no you don't want to marry a
boy or you're a married girl never i
like this but i went to the belly
i make sense
right now
you want to work on take it from me you
get married you [ __ ] lose yourself
self love i'll never get married i want
to keep this belly thank you for tuning
into this episode of matchy we'll see
you guys next time
hey real quick last question actual last
question okay so jk you know we love
each other we love this this room but
we're trying to go younger how do we
reach you guys like in the demographic
that's true how do we reach your friends
yeah how do we change how we make you
guys want to tune in every time
connected
to
friends
we know we know what we got to do stop
mocking us like like how do we connect
your generation yeah we feel too old and
out of time what do we got to do for you
to like us like this make you want to
tune in every time
[Music]
kissing butts oh kissing bus
we got
did you cut it
[Music]
you